I remember when I first started
wondering what it was like not being
Amish I started buying makeup and you
know it just looks so interesting I
wanted to know how much people believe
that the outside world is the devil's
playground
for us to be exposed so that is
basically like playing with fire
they've been so held back from
everything thinking one to the movies
your stuff like that when they get to
you just hit steam they just want to
experience this hell new world
the first turn sixteen going to the mall
is like my dream I felt that I could do
anything I wanted to it's just like oh
cool I can do go to this donut dad
[Music]
the biggest thing that changes when you
turn 16 is you start going to parties
most Amish kids have cell phones so if
one guy decided to have a party at his
place he calls all of his friends they
call all of their friends
within an hour hour and a half everybody
knows about it okay okay yeah that's
dead ends it's a DC coma coming up
[Music]
let's go
Amish kids got the best parties they got
the wild parties